e
good morning everybody Welcome to
Edna everyone is
clerk some reason no he hasn't had a
problem CU he said he he said he was
going to be
here the other person that we need yeah
yes making a dramatic entrance
representative
right all right we
have uh 10 bills to exec today only one
was noticed because I was hoping we'd
get a few of the others taken care of
last week but the uh hearing ran over a
bit
so the uh first one I'd like to do is a
warmup is C
R1
okay representative Bailey moves in
expedient to legislate representative
Schmidt seconds do you wish to speak to
Bailey no I think
it okay representative Schmidt well I
want I appreciate the motion of itl
which is I a motion I was prepared to
make and uh for those who are new to the
committee this term this is a a bill
that we have seen in itl previously at
least twice um and uh while I understand
the the sponsors motivations and so
forth the bottom line is I think that
the bill as written is not viable not
workable uh but that that we have a
situation in the state where we have a
structure in place to handle potential
incapacitations or deaths of the
governor that has worked for over 200
years and we've had exactly one example
of a another Governor dying in office I
and I think that the uh the system that
we have works admirably well and I
appreciate the itl motion by the maker
thereof thank you anyone else have a
comment I'd like to say that our
tradition of electing the governor every
two years means that we're not stuck
or um incompetent Governor well not
incompetent excuse me that's the wrong
word uh incapacitated incapacitated
thank you that's a better word governor
for very long it's not that like the
places where the governor serves for
four or six years um it's it's a short
period of time and I think our our
constitutional protections are are quite
solid or anyone
else representative sloty were going to
say
something you were going to say
something no I'm I'm all set thank you
okay anyone else have a comment
question okay then the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on cac1 and the
clerk can call the
r VI chairman Le on yes and your
it's on
no the clerk votes yes representative
Pierce yes representative Bailey yes
representative Osborne yes
representative sers yes representative
slaty yes representative
tibo yes yes yes
okay uh representative groa
I representative Davis yes
representative Dary yes representative
Howard yes representative dver yes
representative
long yes and the chair yes 160 in itl
all right the motion
passes uh is there any objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
96 is which one is
that what's it the energy code oh energy
represent groa did you have a
motion no I guess
not all right uh since representative
shien can't be here I'll move
itl a
second okay
and I'd like to say that the
subcommittee met on that and going to
the
2021 energy code while the building code
review board is working on reviewing the
code
seems like a waste of effort on
everybody's part and from what I have
heard the 2024 code fixes a great many
errors oh not errors problems with the
21 code so it is a more effective code
in in the first place so I the 21 code
was considered and rejected by both the
building code review board and the
legislature last year and I think going
back to trying adopted on an interim
level is a waste of time uh
representative L uh thank you madam
chair um if the 2021 building uh energy
code was all we had to look at right now
that would be one thing but there's the
2024 energy code that's already being
reviewed you know let's let's keep
working and looking forward instead of
trying to look backwards when we have
another version that's already being
reviewed so that's why I'm voting itl
okay is there any anyone else represent
long uh so I want to say that I like the
concept of this bill but my constituents
are very concerned about the cost of
housing uh especially right now so I
don't think it's the right time for it
uh I would vote for this bill at the
right time uh but I'm not going to today
I'll be voting for the
itl uh I also I feel like the numbers
that were supported or were offered by
both sides were not really supported
sufficiently so I would like to see more
information next time the bill comes
around all right thank you
representative scitech if I may follow
up on representative long because I was
struck by the same point I heard at one
point 29,000 I heard at another Point
2,000 if it were really 2000 we would be
this would be on consent calendar so
it's I'd really like to see
more more data uh and that's that thank
you okay representative
re yeah I'll be voting against uh itl
today because I'm concerned that being
so far behind um the standard is going
to cost New Hampshire some money so um
if we don't get our uh energy code up to
date we miss the opportunity to unlock
Federal funding for New Hampshire so our
state's building codes are not aligned
um which could mean that we would not be
eligible for significant Federal funding
opportunities including grants from the
inflation reduction act infrastructure
investment and jobs Act and the
department of energy programs um this
bill would reduce energy costs for
residents and
businesses uh it enhances our ability to
um or rather helps us to strengthen
climate resilience um and would help the
construction industry and job market so
because we heard two different sets of
data um I'm not sure that the higher
number being offered by a lobbying uh
entity is something that we should be
relying upon so I'm going to vote
against
itl thank you representative scitech
wasn't that higher number rep that was
offered by a lobbyist did that a
lobbyist say that came from uh Senator
sh uh
Shaheen that's what I thought I heard
yeah in any event the the testimony was
that imposing this code would create a
an increas in cost of building and there
were debates over how much but it was
increase anyone else representative
groda thank you
I'll support the itl but not because I
don't like the policy about this bill
because I think that it's important to
consider however I'm uncomfortable with
the back and forth between the different
testimonies that we had and I'm also
concerned about mandating something
that we don't as a committee have the
expertise to understand so I can I know
this bill will come
back and um I plan on learning more
about the costs of Energy Efficiency in
homes and I would encourage other
members of the committee to do it to do
this as well thank you anyone
else all right seeing no uh no further
comments the motion is inexpedient to
legislate and the clerk can call the
the clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative b
i representative Osborne
yes representative sers yes
representative flaty
yes representative TBO
yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt
no representative Davis
yes represent Argie
no representative Howard no represent re
hard
no I'll mark that hard
here representative long
yes and the chair
yes uh 10 to uh 12 to 12 to 12 to 4 okay
the motion passes 12 to four does
someone plan on writing a Minority
Report representative Dev will write a
Minority
Report all right that case it won't go
calendar
okay um
yes I didn't say in my if I can just a
had a postcript I was very impressed
with Mr uh Gage and Mr D re if I've got
not d uh bremis I don't have it right
they are really Ardent supporters and I
really want to hear more from them I
guess so there I am excellent
um as a side note I want to mention to
Representatives Howard and Leon that
they still owe committee reports from
last week
so at your for House Bill 210 the commi
commission representative Howard and uh
You've Got The Minority Report on on the
uh dieti
pact yes I while we're on administrative
things this is the last scheduled
meeting for Edna on house bills thank
you all for plugging along I we have not
yet received any Senate bills or any
second committee bills so I am not going
to be scheduling anything for next
week good job guys and uh we'll see what
happens when we start getting the Senate
bills and the second committee bills if
any and committee reports are due in as
soon as possible they need to be in next
week's calendar if we can get them in
today great if not Monday or I'm going
to be nagging you
uh so moving right along House Bill 161
representative L uh yes I move itl on
House Bill
161 I'll
second okay do you wish to speak to your
motion uh yes thank you madam chair um I
I think that one of the things that was
highlighted in the testimony is that
there's still a lot of disagreement
within the community uh but that the
largest glaring issue is that right now
the membership is not filled in the
commission um we we were told of the
five vacant seats but there are also
four additional terms that have expired
um some that expired just a week ago so
right now there are only two Governor
appointed members of the commission and
then the four that are appointed
otherwise giving them a membership of
six with the bill that we passed last
year to allow a quorum to be 50% plus
one right now a quorum of the Native
American Affairs commission is only four
members and that could override those
who do were appointed because of their
native Heritage um to me that brings a
pretty troubling concern about its
viability especially as I reviewed the
um annual reports and the only time that
the commission was fully filled was when
it was first created in
2010 additionally there are more annual
reports missing than are published and
the most recent was
2022 um I'm an itl on this bill and I
strongly want to encourage enourage both
the governor to nominate people to the
commission and for those involved to
determine um the necessity of the
commission going forward Because unless
there's some changes and improvements
I'm not sure how much it benefits the
state and I might look to repeal the
commission next year because it doesn't
seem to be functional and is drawing PE
drawing their attention away from the
internal affairs and their relationship
with um other bands other tribes in the
federal government um in order to try
and deal with some New Hampshire
creative bureaucracy so I'm hopeful that
they'll be able to have people Nam to
the commission that this will move
forward and it'll start working in a
good and effective way um but if we
don't see otherwise um i' I'd be apt to
uh look to end it next next year if we
don't see progress represent BR do you
wish to speak to your second no thank
you representative scitec uh this bill
uh more than almost any other has caused
me to reflect on our job as
Representatives
uh for me I have no interest in this
issue but I took an oath and I got on
this committee so I have to take this
issue seriously the
way as seriously as the people proposing
it and I prepared the minutes for this
it's a it's a nightmare to try to figure
out if I were emperor of the world I
wouldn't know quite what to do and so it
something has to be done
uh but I don't know what that something
is and it's challenge thank you for
listening represent
schm thank you madam chair uh and I
appreciate representative scitec remarks
because I am also very troubled by the
situation and representative Leon's uh
remarks also are very pertinent uh we've
heard allegations about why they can't
get a membership so they would could
have an ordinarily function commission
with a with a quorum that shows up and
so forth uh and we've heard allegations
about why uh there haven't been
appointments and so forth and so on but
as it is uh we were left in a situation
where uh where this committee would have
to make decisions with regard to a
culture which we have next to no
familiarity with we know I I know a
whole handful of people who turned out
to be indigenous I never knew because
they don't look any different than us uh
and uh and so the question of of how
their culture and how there these
administrative Affairs that we get
confronted with over and over again uh
how those the those are to be understood
and to be appropriately legislated but
without it I'm not going to I'm not
going to vote on a bill that that I have
no sense of certainty about what what
we're doing so so I I also strongly
support the idea represent uh if
footnote to representative Schmidt one
of the about not recognizing some people
as indigenous one of the testifiers was
a fellow teacher at Salem
High amazing I didn't never
know as the sponsor of this
bill I was expecting some opposition but
I was really shocked by the amount of
conflict within the Native American
community in New
Hampshire and I had a report from one of
them that the issues are from the time
of King Philip's War in the
1700s well we're not going to solve that
by any easy Manner and then we got a
letter from the abanaki council from in
Quebec which is the center of the nation
and they're concerned and they're also
very concerned with the Vermont state
recognition they believe that that
process was
incorrect and at that point if it's
between the abanaki nation and the state
of Vermont and the state of New
Hampshire I don't want to get in the
middle of this I think that is
definitely above our pay grade we ought
to let the parties involved deal with it
themselves and I mean a commission's not
not going to do make a big deal either
way but I think we ought to
say the issues are beyond our
scope anyone
else all right thank you the motion is
in expedient to legislate on House Bill
161 cler can call the
r Vice chairman Lon yes clerk votes yes
representative peerce yes represent
Bailey I
wasn't sure which one it would be
representative Osborne yes
representative sers yes representative
Cuchi yes representative Teo
yes representative groden yes
representative Schmid yes representative
Davis yes representative Argy
yes representative Howard yes
representative Tes yes representative
long yes and the chair Yes sounds like
16's to zero okay is there any objection
to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that one on
consent all right looking at who's here
I think we'll move on to House Bill
428 representative
Lon um yes do we have that Amendment yes
I think we we were given it some time
I believe this is the amendment oh that
okay all right if someone who can find
the amendment we were given some time
ago this is the one that uh
representative Shen passed out and was
right sorry I thought it was coming
today sorry about that
uh representative de excuse me what
number is this again what number is this
again that's what we're trying to find
out because I don't it's House Bill
428 and SEC and representative sh had an
amendment which she presented I believe
you were at that executive and we
decided to set it aside because do you
have the amendment by I'm sure that I do
okay great could you just give keep this
much paper around for nothing all right
we'll see if you can find that number Mr
Sherman do you I gave you my copy can
number 28 H oh I'm sorry yes 328 H okay
thank you somebody's found it 328 H all
right we're missing a digit
032 all right that's moved by
representative Lon I'll second and I
would like to ask Mr Sherman who's the
chair of the building code review board
to explain to us why we need
question to the chair yes sir would it
be possible that we could res recess
this uh momentarily so that we can get
at it with a little bit more time to
pull our act together um I would like to
have Mr Sherman explain why we need them
first while everybody I'm happy with
that digs through their piles of papers
amendment Madam chair member of the
members of the committee um I came here
today to listen so
here we are uh this the bill proper
proposes to eliminate all local
amendments to the State Building Code
this amendment does a couple of things
um it maintains the ability for
municipalities to do administrative
amendments and by that I mean if you've
been into the model codes it's
essentially chapter one stuff so it's
how do you get a permit how do you deal
with inspections how do you deal with
CER certificates of occupancy fee
schedules those kinds of things um
currently the way we adopt the building
codes the language in the model codes is
co-equal to any other language in
statute according to doj so that gives
us the need to be able to uh modify some
of this stuff where you know a city of
Manchester operates their processes
differently than some small town it
administrative should not in fact uh
impact how the building itself is
constructed we're referring to those as
technical amendments so administrative
as paperwork process those kinds of
things and we've tried to Define that in
here um whereas technical as with the
base bill would still be
prohibited the second thing this does is
that um HB 241 which is is I think going
to a a longer term study um attempts to
take the various places that the State
Building Code has addressed and get it
all into
155a a lot of these tentacles still
reside in in RSA 674 and other land use
chapters and it's very confusing as I
understand it to the people out there
enforcing things because many of them
enforce both land use and building codes
so we're just trying to take some of the
old language that's been there for a
long long time and get it into
155a on the issues that are involved
with Municipal amendments and
specifically
67451 this amendment just gets them over
into 155a so we don't have to change
them once and then turn around and
change it again probably next year to
get them into the right spot so there's
a fair amount of ink in here but but
much of it is simply language that's in
67451 now we've brought it in eliminated
some duplication cleaned up some
terminology so that everybody's using
the same words but primarily this is
intended to permit these administrative
amendments which I I think personally
are necessary uh to
operate okay representative re thank you
madam chair so in reading this amendment
I want to make sure that I'm firmly
understanding this with the the
distinction between the technical and
administ admin ministrative so sorry I'm
not well um the the technical changes
this would bar municipalities make sure
I'm understanding this bar
municipalities from setting a higher
standard on the building code a
technical standard for example another
foot of free board or another two feet
of free board is that correct that's the
intent of the base Bill and this
amendment doesn't change that intent so
yes okay so it would actually it m sorry
Madam chair it would actually take away
the right of municipalities to set
higher standards than the building code
is that correct that's the intent of the
you all right are there any other
questions for Mr
Sherman all right seeing none thank you
very much for that information I wasn't
sure why we needed them until I until
you explained that the building code had
things like fees and uh permit
procedures which
are obviously going to vary between say
Manchester and
abson any other
comments person SL you just just getting
yeah
okay
stff I'm so glad you're having a good
time to gentlemen anyone else comments
questions all right
um just for ease of discussion I'd like
to i' encourage you to support the
amendment even if you don't support the
concept of the bill because this does
not change the concept of the bill it
simply makes it feasible for the
administrative items representative gr
yes I I will I support support the
amendment I will not support the bill
but I do appreciate the work that was
done on the amendment and I thank you so
I'll second okay I take it that was a
motion to no the motion has was made by
representative Lyon and seconded By Me
Oh but we haven't voted on it how
quickly we forget okay any further
comments questions
discussion represent PCH uh in a brief
part of my career I actually build some
houses and we were very fortunate that
we had good inspectors but it wasn't
hard to see how the code could
be weaponized and um I think the
practicalities of this
are important that uh I don't want to
see there's a sense that the towns are
going to be even better than the state
code and I believe the state code
is uh plenty good
enough um that's my experience thank
you represent long so this is another
bill where uh my constituent's concerned
about housing costs is my overriding
concern uh and determining my vote uh so
I will be voting for the bill I will
vote for the amendment uh but I do think
that Municipal governments have tended
to abuse the powers that they've had uh
and take away the freedoms of their
citizen and that has resulted in uh
being very hard to find an affordable
place to live these
days
yes yeah and the the point that so many
people eager
for uh Advanced housing or extremely
efficient buildings or whatever forget
is that the state building code is the
minimum it is not a stretch code it is
the the minimum minum for safety
required to to to build in the state and
that's and that's why I'm concerned
about Municipal amendments besides the
fact that as representative long said
they're subject to
abuse um particularly before we
instituted a formal a requirement that
Municipal amendments be formally
adopted there were many many cases of
individual building inspectors making up
the rules as they went along not all of
them not but it it happened enough that
we heard about it from many people and
if
they're having a basic Statewide
building code should prevent that from
happening in the future anybody
else all right not seeing anybody the
motion is to adopt Amendment 0328 to
House Bill 428 representative who made
the motion Mr L on representative L made
the motion I second
okay you can call the role now that
you're ready I am ready um Vice chairman
leyon yes the clerk was yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I representative
Osborne yes representative sers yes
representative
rep representative grod yes
representative Schmid yes represent
Davis yes representative Dary yes
representative Howard yes represent Rees
yes representative long yes the chair
yes on the amendment
160 all right the amendment passes
representative Lon um yes I I move ought
to pass as Amendment
by the amendment we just adopted
you
okay all right so now that we've made
the the bill feasible is there any
discussion representative Leon uh thank
you madam chair um I think it is very CR
crucial to understand that these are the
bare minimums that allow people to have
housing that is is safe and allows them
to live um and that these also apply
when you have Renovations as well so I
want to ensure that we aren't having uh
people in the granite state who are
afraid to make necessary improvements
just because it moves them past that
that point where we they need uh they
need to have code updates and I'd rather
have them improve their home as
necessary in a way that they can afford
and that they can work with without
having the Quagmire of having a hard
time finding a builder because they
don't want to deal with their talent
because their Town hasn't been
transparent about what changes are made
um as it is as it is it's hard to find
somebody to work with hard to find some
it's hard to find the right person
because there's so many different styles
and if you're excluding people that
don't want to work with a difficult town
that becomes even more difficult and
more expensive for the people that we
represent um so I believe that this is
important to have consistency among the
state and as a when I do build an early
adopter a lot of these Innovations I'm
sure I'll be going above and beyond but
I'm not going to force my neighbor who's
choosing between doing an important
renovation to replace things and keep
things safe and uh putting food on the
table represent zelers do you wish to
speak to your motion your a second yeah
thank you madam CL the the point I want
to drive was if you had
multiple codes you had to follow it's
going to drive housing up especially in
uh specific towns or cities and if I was
a builder I'd ought to let I I'd have to
automatically know saying oh if I go to
Manchester it's going to cost me $20,000
more to build this house so I'm gonna up
my price automatically just because I
have to follow a different building code
I think it's just it's it's going to
drive the price of housing up if we have
multiple codes to follow thank you
anyone else representative de re yeah I
I think I have to go in on um local
control here uh this bill we this sets a
minimum and what it is doing is saying
that municipalities cannot then add to
that so the provisions that my town
takes in adding to requirements for our
building code if this passes is going to
go away so our town my town has a severe
flooding problem and so we have a
requirement that an extra foot of free
Board needs to be added that is not
adding significantly to people's housing
cost that is not the core of our
affordable housing problem what it does
is it helps to protect the people who
are building new homes to ensure that
those properties are sustainable for a
longer period of time and their asset is
protected so I am absolutely for setting
minimums that's great but the provision
as part of this amendment as part of
this bill that municipalities cannot add
to that um and and in order to add to it
they've got to get the permission of
their voters my understanding um but
they cannot add to that is problematic
because it takes away the right of
municipalities to set condition to set
requirements that respond to local
conditions so for that reason I'll be
voting against this you representative
Lam uh thank you madam chair I I do want
to say that I do believe in local
control and a lot of that local control
comes to somebody looking at the
situation looking and having the
education which still can be provided to
have the education that perhaps you
should have more freeboard to protect
against flooding but I'm looking at
those households and those individuals
that are making these choices um and not
say the 1900 people out of a 35,000
person in town that showed up to vote
yesterday uh because local control works
when people are locally involved and I
believe at the ultimate local control
which is our
citizens
okay representative re one rebuttal
thank you um this is taking away local
control absolutely and I just want to
make sure that I'm Crystal Clair about
that okay it is any other anyone else
want to make a
comment all right the motion is ought to
pass with amendment by representative
Lon and the clerk call the role Vice
chairman Lon yes the clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes represent
Bailey I representative uh Osborne
yes representative sers yes yes
representative sloty yes representative
tibo yes Representative groda no I'm
sorry say again please
no uh representative Schmidt no
representative Davis no represent Argy
no representative Howard no
Representative dver no representative
long yes and the chair yes okay two four
six 10 to six
um okay the motion passes
10-6 this will not go on consent uh is
someone writing a m Minority Report yes
someone will I'm not sure who
okay we'll uh assign representative
raise for the moment if that's
okay uh unless others otherwise changed
the clerk would like to pencil in you
and you can change that if you like but
I need something thank
you I'm sure our ranking member can find
somebody better I'm sure you can get
help no no question about it all right
that's that
one okay moving on to something a little
less contentious representative Schmidt
you have a motion on House Bill
192 I do Madam chair there's an
amendment as you know so I I move I
ought to pass on the amendment which is
87h adopt okay I'll second
that okay do you wish to speak to your
motion yes uh so for those of you who
are new this time around this deals with
the joint committee on employee
classification on which I serve along
with representative scitec for many
years we served on this committee which
is a ministerial committee uh and the
amendment deal with an oversight in the
adoption of the uh updated uh rules for
this term um so uh as you will see line
four adds in uh the deputy director of
Medical Services uh at salary rate uh
level
GG in somebody in the Department of
Corrections uh so that's the whole
purposes is to uh correct that
Omission
okay second or I'll just mention that
this is the normal process for um these
positions their salary grade is reviewed
and a by an outs by an outside expert
The Joint Committee on employee
classification reviews and approves it
and then there's a
bill this is the bill anyone else have a
question comment
concern just if I just may add in so our
Edna's role in this is to is
to approve the language of the action
that the uh JCC has taken previously we
JCC is the executive body uh and our
role is to actually put it into the
statute then it moves on to finance
where they where they approve the the
funding
thereof thank you okay thank you
representative cite representative re
might like to know that we retain local
control over that we don't always follow
the um recommendation of hay corn furry
and their golf tournament um so I just
that okay anyone else all right the
motion is to adopt amendment
0587 to house Bill 192 and the clerk can
call the role Vice chairman Leon yes the
clerk votes yes representative Pearson
yes representative Bailey I
representative Osborne yes
representative sers yes representative
yes representative Teo yes
representative Broda yes representative
Schmidt I representative Davis yes
representative Dary yes representative
Howard yes representative Tes yes
representative long yes and the
chair yes ran
slam okay reprend Schmidt I move uh
ought to pass with
Amendment there a
second I'll second it thank
you do you wish to speak to your
motion I think we've said it all okay
I'm good thanks okay anyone else have a
comment question
concern okay the motion is off to pass
with Amendment on House Bill 192 and the
clerk can call the
role Vice chairman Lan
yes clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative Bailey I
representative Osborne yes
representative sers yes representative s
yes representative tibo yes
representative Gro yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Davis yes
representative dargy yes representative
Howard yes representative Rees yes
representative long yes and the chair
yes
160 okay the motion passes 16 to zero
any any objections to
consent nope okay that one will go on
consent
also uh House Bill 271 representative
groa yes thank you Madame
chair I move a to pass on Amendment
04958 for House Bill
second do you wish to speak to your
motion yes so there was a concern
between the licensing the board and the
association the social workers
Association
and the um differences were resolved in
the sub
committee and it asks the board to come
to design a test that is appropriate for
an
associate uh social worker and that is
how um the amendment was
crafted okay and I like to mention that
the testimony showed that the test that
was in originally required was not
relevant to the duties of the social
work
Associates and therefore only one person
had bothered to take the test uh if we
I'm not sure we need to have a licensed
Social Work ass associate but if we do
we need to make sure the qualifications
are actually relevant to the job and
this will make it
so anyone
else thank you M thank you madam chair
so and the bottom line here is not only
what the chair just said but also the
fact that uh the the pay for this job is
not commensurate with the difficulty in
in jumping through all the hoops and
that net effect is they're very short on
actual worker bees so uh this should
open the door to a more reasonable uh
pool of people willing to do the job for
the pay off thank you all right anyone
else repres um experience again I have a
daughter who is an APRN and U she passed
all the tests but they were minimum
requirements the real education started
uh when we added to the code and she was
on the floor that's where it really
happened uh but without the groundwork
it would not have been effective
okay anyone
else all right the motion is to accept
Amendment
0495 H to House Bill 271 Clerk and call
the r represent Vice chairman Lon yes
clerk votes yes representative Pearson
yes representative Bailey I
representative Osborne yes
representative sers yes representative
Sal yes representative tibo yes
representative groa yes representative
yes representative Davis
yes representative Dary yes
representative Howard
yes representative Tes yes
representative L yes and the chair yes
160 on the adoption of the amendment
okay representative gr yes thank you I
move a to pass with Amendment for House
Bill 271 second okay move by
representative Roa second by
representative
Schmidt
and any further
discussion no thank you repres Leon uh
thank you madam chair I will Echo your
question as to whether the licensed
Social Work associate is necessary but
we definitely don't need to have
additional hurdles um if anybody does
think that that's that's a necessary
role
okay any other comments questions all
right those in favor cler call the RO
okay on uh what to passes with Amendment
uh Vice chairman Leon yes repres the
chair the clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative Bailey
I representative Osborne yes
representative sers yes representative
yes representative tibo yes
representative Gren yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Davis yes
representative dargy yes representative
Howard yes representative dver re yes
representative long yes and the chair
yes 160 what the pass with Amendment
okay motion passes 16 to zero any
objections to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
consent and while we're so agreeable I
on House Bill
214 I move amendment number
0845 and I'll just say that this is the
language on criminal record checks that
that
was that has been suggested by the
department of safety as meeting the
requirements and it makes them happy
since they have to do the work I'm I
think we ought to make them happy and
that's that's all this amendment does is
revise the
language uh on how to get a record
check representative
lamb um don't need to say anything thank
you okay anyone else have a comment
question on the
amendment seeing none all right uh the
clerk can call the role on the amendment
okay we're adopt we're motion is to
adopt
88845 on
hb214 rep uh Vice chairman Leon yes
clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative Bailey I not
too late for yes you know um
representative osbor yes representative
yes representative SL yes representative
tibo yes representative groa yes
representative Schmid yes representative
Davis yes representative Argy yes
representative Howard yes representative
T yes representative long yes and chair
you and I'll move ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill
second
and um I spoke too much too quickly on
House
Bill uh 82 this is also still cleanup of
the uh regulatory Authority of the oplc
uh it makes some minor comments and uh
clarifies the rul making and takes care
of the criminal record checks to the
um other than clarifying that the um
the record the criminal records check is
needed it is not a change in scope it's
a more statutory
cleanup and if anyone has a question
representative L done need I think okay
concerns okay not seeing any the motion
is ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 214 and the clerk can call the
role Vice chairman Leon yes clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey
I representative Osborne yes
representative sers yes representative
SL yes representative tibo yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Davis yes
repres representative Dary yes
representative Howard yes representative
D yes representative long yes and the
chair yes and that's uh 1601 okay motion
passes any objections to
consent okay seeing none that'll be on
right house bill 694 representative
Lon um thank you I move um motion to
2025-the
of the original Bill looking at any
lease with the with the subdivisions um
this one only deals with political
subdivisions and leases is um with the
state this is a small bite at the Apple
but this is something that'll address
the largest issues that we saw around
the prices charged um to use courtrooms
and and other Municipal land I think
that this is a good way to get good
Clarity and make sure that one one group
of taxpayers isn't subsidizing another
in One Direction or the other and um so
option all right representative Aly
nothing to add all right any comments
amendment I I'd like to say that we were
concerned
that the state was attempting to more or
less bully the political
subdivisions uh during the lease
negotiations and this will give them a
bit
more um
I don't know more more standing to to
say what the mar the fair price for
renting a building is a lot of these are
extremely unique I mean how many people
want to rent a
courthouse but uh if you start with the
concept that it's a fair market
rate then at least the and utilities and
custodial services and so forth are in
addition to the basic rate that'll keep
the counties and cities from being um
forced to subsidize the
state and I think that's an important
issue anyone out represent BR yes um I
have a note that there was a drafting
error on the bill but I noticed that the
reference the RGA I mean RSA was was
eliminated in the amendment and is that
because a drafting error yeah that was
the drafting error but because it was
eliminated I'm thinking it was
eliminated because we changed the scope
of the bill we changed the scope of the
bill to only deal with leases between
the state and a political subdivision
the original Bill had all leases from
the state and we didn't think we needed
to protect the private landlords for
from uh what I've heard from from
various uh State officials the private
landlords do a fine job of negotiating
profitable rates with the state
okay it's that's their business after
all representative uh oh representative
daring yeah uh one other change on the
bill was that uh with the amendment is
that it goes both ways it's not
just um the state and the political
subdivision it goes both ways so if uh
subdivision owns a property and the
state's leasing it it's it's okay or if
the state has a property and the
political subdivision leasing it it's
the same deal it's both at um Market
rates um thank you for that
clarification it's
important okay any
other comments
questions all right the motion is is to
adopt Amendment 0889 H and the clerk can
call the
role Vice chairman Leon yes clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I representative
Osborne yes representative sers yes
representative yes representative
tibo
yes representative grod yes
representative Schmid yes representative
Davis yes representative Dary yes
representative Howard yes represent
D yes
representative long yes the chair yes we
have a 160 on the adoption of the
amendment represent of land um yes I
move ought to pass on House Bill 694 as
amended by Amendment
0889 with Amendment 8 with Amendment
sorry 889 thank you all right is there a
second thank
you all right any further comments
questions
concerns all right seeing none the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on House Bill 694 and the clerk can call
the vote Vice chairman Leon yes clerk
votes yes representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I representative
Osborne yes representative s yes
representative sloty yes representative
tibo yes representative grota yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
dargy yes representative Howard yes
representative Rees yes representative
long yes and the chair yes 160 all right
motion passes uh any objections to
consent
all right seeing none that will be on
consent okay House Bill 252
representative
slot you have a motion yes thank you I'd
like to motion uh itl
please is there a
second second second
okay wish do you wish to speak to your
motion no
thanks representative
lamb um yes thank you madam chair um
there's the issue around how many
holidays do we recognize as a state um
as we add more and more we sort of
dilute the power of each and any history
teacher in the state should be well
aware of Daniel Webster and already
including them um robustly in the
education and therefore while I
appreciate bringing more attention to
Daniel Webster um I also recognize that
this should already be happening and
adding an additional day um is not going
recognition it's been the tradition of
this committee not to support special
holidays because the state doesn't have
a method by which to enact what we ask
them to
do and until there is such a mechanism
um we should continue the tradition and
the uh protocol for the division for the
committee and I apologize to you
representative
Tio yeah representative
Tio uh I just wanted to say I appreciate
the committee's concerns I will be
voting against itl because Daniel
Webster was from Franklin and I I want
to pay respect to him but um I do think
that there are better ways out there to
um appreciate New Hampshire history and
I look forward to working in the
legislature to celebrate those in the
future good representative Schmidt thank
you madam Sher so representative
um Daniel Webster is uh unforgotten and
those who bump into his statue un
knowingly down in front of the state
house um will will look up and say who's
that guy uh in in the case of people who
maybe will be forgotten
um in another hundred years um if if
there's a if there's cause to want to
remember them it's this committee's
position that the proclamation by the
governor is uh is more likely to to
attract some attention in that
particular era um as we did with Granny
D for example who was a a really
outstanding citizen but in 100 years
she may be
forgotten
fortunately uh so to the degree that
that would be the case with Daniel
Webster I would think we would all be
very surprised uh since he's also got a
portrait up in the front of the Reps
Hall um so that's the reason we don't go
for this kind of Bill in this committee
thank you yes I'd like to expound on
that because we have found that if an a
person or a town or an
organization best itself to want to
create a special day they celebrate it
they get the governor to an to announce
that day and they perform the uh uh
whatever
appropriate actions are required whether
it's in the school or the town or
putting up a statue of Pana I mean any
whatever they're involved but once it
gets into statute it's
forgotten it's the governor issues a
proclamation that nobody is waiting for
and nobody does much of anything uh
we've had the occasion of holding a
hearing on February 14th one year and
someone wanted a special day I forget
exactly what event it was and I asked
her do you know what today is and well
of course it's Valentine's Day no it's
the state holiday of genital heart
disease day and everybody oh wow no one
knew that because it was it had been
lobbied for and people had pushed for it
and it was placed into the statute and
that was
it so I'm very much against establishing
holidays in statute
represent Madam chair did you say best
themselves I'm going to have to go to my
Websters on that one uh
I we always have some vocabulary lessons
in every exact session uh indeed uh a
couple things first as I understand the
choice of date was right after Martin
Luther King day wasn't
it that wasn't the intent that's just
happens to be his
birthday okay I think that that tends to
be in the penumbra of uh Martin Luther
King I'd like to vote for it but here's
the deal uh he's conspicuous by his
absence I mean if we're going to do this
for the other people uh the forebears of
of our state we would to include him but
uh no not I don't know I I'll Pro I may
weaken at some point but that's my my
thinking i' yes and I would have to say
that any um history teacher that didn't
know about Daniel
Webster probably shouldn't be teaching
no
history any other comments con
questions represent Bailey was it just a
grotesque coincidence that congenital
heart disease day is the same as
Valentine's Day no I believe that was
deliberate but that that was put into
you anyone
else okay the motion is inexpedient to
Bill uh
252 and the clerk can call the
role represent uh Vice chairman leyon
yes and as another rep might say a soft
no a soft yes sorry uh representative
Pearson yes representative Bailey I
representative Osborne yes
representative sers yes representative
sloty a medium
yes getting sof
represento
no Representative groa no I mean yes yes
yes please it's a yes was that a hard or
a soft who a definite yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Davis no no
representative dargy yes representative
Howard I'm gonna have to go with another
soft yes I
mean I know how it feels representative
re for clarification this is was an itl
motion right yes yeah I'm a
no uh representative long I'll uh
complete the set and go with a soft no
soft no and the chair
yes four 12
to4 all right the motion passes 12 to4
Report what yes no okay anyone else m I
have a question then are is this going
to get floor fought are we going to are
we going to fight this on the floor well
that's why I'm doing the questions in
order the first question is is there
going to be a Minority Report if there
is it is definitely going to be on the
regular calender right and I think
that's something that we should
probably think about right now are we
going to actually floor fight this
because if we're not it should just
probably go on consent if I can make a
comment I think that that really is up
to the four people have voted no yes and
so if one of them chooses to write a
Minority Report then it's on the cons
it's on the regular calendar if you
choose not to it's on the consent
calendar and we can give you like a few
minutes to think about it
but yes representative
tuo Madam chair I would just like to say
that um I would prefer that this go on
consense so I'd ask my colleagues who um
also voted in the negative to um to
respect that if they'd like that's and
that's why I'm asking if they do want to
write a Minority
Report no doesn't it look a little funny
to have a a for vote uh it happens I
don't
know
don't all right representative Schmidt
is objecting to consent I I see that no
one
is planning to write a Minority Report
is that
correct but we can still have a Voice
vote on the thing exactly okay so this
this will go on the regular
calendar and no no Minority Report
representative ree may we defer to the
bill sponsor on whether or not he wants
a floor fight on this he has said he
doesn't doesn't want it to be fact he
asked for Beyond consent correct okay so
12 to4 regardless I there was support
for rento's Bill but I I don't don't see
bringing this to the floor for a floor
battle with a discussion debate when
when the bill sponsor doesn't want that
a representative Schmidt has said it
should not be on consent and therefore
it will not be on consent got four votes
is too many to have on consent I either
way you're objecting represent Pearson's
concerned yes represent would it be
possible for to change my vote um at
this point no at this point it doesn't
you could do a motion to reconsider will
it will just come up it will just come
up it'll get voted on there won't be any
fight all up Daniel portrait on the
house remember
him one more time I think if we don't
plan to argue it we can leave it on the
regular calendar and
just
Daniel Madam chair I think we're ready
to move on thank you all right we are
moving on to the last bill we have which
is House Bill
610 and I I have an amendment
that
incorporates the office of the consumer
advocate in the department of energy for
your
consideration but after re reading this
retain
okay I move to retain House Bill
and
I'll the cons the current consumer
Advocate obviously has a lot
but I was concerned that the utilities
that he's supposed to be representing
consumers against were all supporting
him that struck me as something a little
weird um I was also concerned that the
chair of the science and energy
committee was concerned that the scope
of the consumer Advocates activity ities
was either not properly defined in
statute
or he was working outside of the scope
and he thought that that needed to be
fixed that's not our our wheelhouse
really we don't we don't deal with him
we don't know what he does but I have a
lot of concerns about this and so I
suggested retaining it so that we can
find out what's going on the the hearing
was a very well
orchestrated uh evidence of support but
like I said I was concerned that the
utilities weren't
saying God this this this office is a
nuisance they bother us they keep us
from making our proper and appropriate
profits but they didn't say that they
said he's a good guy and he works hard I
mean
that's um I was concerned so I I think
we ought to at least hold on to it for a
little while while and
say is the consumer Advocate doing the
right thing and
is a not even barely administratively
attached the department of energy the
right location in the state structure
for it and that's um that was that's my
point representative Lan you wish to
speak to it uh yes thank you madam chair
um I agree I think that one of the
things that I always look for is making
sure that somebody is fighting for the
little guy and the fact that the people
who the office of the consumer Advocate
is supposed to stand up for the little
guy against were supporting the
continuation of the office which just
has me concerned I think that if we
retain this we can just sort of look and
make sure that they are they do have the
tools that they need in order to make
sure that they're representing the
residential rate holders and I think
it's I think it's important to retain
this just because just because right now
we're facing some pretty high energy
costs and we need to make sure that um
either this the consumer advocate's
doing what they need to do and uh
determine whether it's an effective job
and if they need other tools or if it's
simply um something that's necessary to
continue
with anyone else have a
comite it is possible for both teams to
any other comments questions
concerns that present
Schmid it can't do any harm to look at
this a little bit more that's all you're
else okay the motion is to retain House
Bill 610 and the clerk can call the role
Vice chairman Lon yes the clerk votes
yes representative
Pearson yes representative Bailey
I uh o representative oor yes
representative sers yes representative
yes representative tibo yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Davis yes
representative dargy yes representative
Howard yes representative dver yes
representative long yes and the chair
yes 160 to retain okay this will not be
on any calendar as is the the case of
all motions to
retain all right that is our last Bill
thank you all for for working through
this
um everyone your committee reports are
due at your very earliest conven
and have a nice have a nice week off
next week because we will not be having
any Committee
Action all right when will the Senate
pill start coming over uh not right away
I talked to Senator Pearl about it all